- Welcome back.
I'm Taraji Henson, filling
in for Kelly today.
If you know me, you know
I'm a huge animal lover.
So I'm very excited about my next guest.
They're a family
of animal lovers from
down under. (chuckles)
They're also the stars of
Crikey! It's the Irwins,
which is back for season four
on Animal Planet and Discovery Plus.
(birds chirping)
- [Bindi] I love that everyday
brings a new happy moment.
A new challenge.
- Look, Grace.
There's Africa!
- Can you see the rhinos out there?
They've spotted you.
- This would be the ultimate Lion King.
- It actually would.
- Actually would be
pretty awesome.
- Let's go to pride rock.
- I've never worried so much in my life.
Okay, there's a buggy coming.
- She's so sleepy.
- Because I want her to be
absolutely healthy and happy
a hundred percent of the time.
- Who is that?
Who is that?
Ooh.
(audience clapping)
- Please welcome Terri,
Bindi and Robert Irwin.
Welcome!
(music band flourishing)
What do you have there?
- It's a little tortoise, here.
Isn't he cute?
He's so good.
- Oh my goodness.
- And a little echidna
over there as well.
- Yep, yep.
I've got an echidna.
Echidnas are actually
related to the platypus,
so they're egg laying mammals.
They're pretty cute.
- Oh my goodness--
(bird chirping)
Who's making that noise?
- (laughs) We have lots
of birds behind us.
We're actually at our beautiful
wildlife sanctuary here,
which is really special.
And so our gardens are
filled with animals roaming
and that's what you can
hear in the background.
- [Taraji] Oh my goodness.
I wish I was there.
It looks so peaceful.
Your little baby is so cute.
Does she have a favorite
animal at the zoo?
- She does, actually.
My beautiful daughter is so sweet.
She loves all animals,
but actually her favorites are tortoises.
She likes tortoises.
These guys are the elongated tortoises,
but she likes the giant Aldabra tortoises.
We have one tortoise named Igloo,
and these tortoises are huge.
Like, they come up to my hip.
They're massive.
(Robert laughing)
They're like these giant tortoise whales,
and Igloo is her best friend.
- Wow.
- She goes up to Igloo
and tries to pat him,
and he runs to her.
- It's adorable.
- Which is quite slow,
but really cute to see.
- Yes!
- They have this adorable bond.
I know, I love that my
daughter's best friend
is a giant tortoise.
It's hilarious. (laughs)
- Well, I'm a fan of
your daughter's cheeks.
She has the juiciest cheeks.
(Taraji laughing)
- (laughs) Thank you.
- She is very squishy.
- Oh my goodness.
You did something special in
your daughter's honor recently.
What was it?
- I did actually.
When beautiful Grace Warrior was born,
my first words were that
she's our graceful warrior,
and that's actually how she got her name.
And so in her honor,
I got graceful warrior tattooed on my arm
in my dad's handwriting.
(Taraji cooing)
So that my beautiful daughter
and my dad could always be
together and be with me.
And I think it's really special
to have them close to me always,
no matter what happens in life.
And so I'm really blessed.
(audience clapping)
I have such a wonderful family,
and I feel like dad is always with us
in everything that we do.
- That is so beautiful.
I also have my son's
name tattooed right here
on the vein that leads to my heart.
- [Robert] Beautiful.
- Exactly!
- [Taraji] Yeah, so I understand.
- So special.
- And Robert, you just turned 18,
so you're officially a grown man.
How did you celebrate?
- I know!
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, it's a huge milestone.
It feels very surreal.
It was a really wonderful
little celebration at the zoo
just with friends and family here at home,
but it is definitely really exciting.
You know, wildlife conservation
is everything to us.
Protecting our world wildlife,
and now turning 18,
I get to be more stuck in
with all of the different
conservation work that we do
around the world.
So it really is a big honor
for me to get to work full time
and enter this wonderful
new chapter of life.
It's really exciting.
I'm very, very proud, definitely.
- Congratulations.
Congratulations.
(audience clapping)
Terri, this new season covers a lot.
What can people expect?
- Well, we are just going hammer and tong
over here at Australia zoo.
We've got a beautiful wildlife hospital
where we've treated over 110,000 animals,
so it's a lot of action with echidnas.
I don't know what the deal was,
but we just kept getting
little orphaned echidnas in,
and we raised them up and
released them back to the wild,
but it's all the dramas of raising babies.
And when the echidnas are tiny,
when they first hatch out of the egg,
they look kind of like jelly bean blobs.
They're really funny.
- They're hilarious.
- They don't have any spikes,
and they're really weird,
and that's kind of fun to see.
And then, of course, it's
keeping our animals happy.
So it's making sure they
have beautiful homes
and wonderful environments to live in.
And it's all the dramas
of reconstructing beautiful habitat areas,
and you were moving alligators.
- A lot of animal rescues as well.
A lot of what we do is going
out and rescuing animals
that are in need.
So there's some
really exciting, scary,
heart-pounding moments
and some special family times as well.
It's a very personal look
into to how we continue this
incredible wildlife legacy.
Yeah, I think Grace is
the star of the show.
- [Bindi And Robert] She is.
- I'm sure.
She's stalling with those
cheeks, I'll tell you that.
(audience clapping)
And when I come to Australia,
I'm coming.
I'm coming to visit you guys.
- Yes.
- Yes!
- Definitely.
- Definitely do.
- You're a wildlife warrior.
- Always welcome.
- Yes!
Take care, and I'm coming for Grace!
'Cause I wanna see those cheeks!
(Taraji laughing)
- Yes! (laughs)
- Take care, stay safe.